foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Hogwarts lovable gamekeeper
Hagrid what do we really know about
rubius Hagrid The Towering half giant
seemed to be a simple content
groundskeeper but when we look back over
the years Hagrid's life was filled with
tragedy and all sorts of challenges what
happened to him and how did he overcome
everything that's what we'll answer
today parents Hagrid's parentage was a
pretty poorly kept secret to most it
seemed obvious that he was born from a
mixed relationship between a giant Tess
and a wizard still Hagrid tried to keep
the details a secret at times although
he never quite fooled anyone his mother
was known as Fred welfare since we don't
have the clearest records we can't be
sure when she was born but fruit welfare
must have been at least a few decades
old when she gave birth to Hagrid in
1928. like any other Giant Fred welfare
was well over 20 feet tall and a force
to be reckoned with with a natural
resistance to most spells and curses it
would have taken over half a dozen
Wizards to defeat Hagrid's mother in a
fight for that reason the Wizarding
World feared giants like Fred welfare
most of all which makes her marriage to
Hagrid's father all the stranger at some
point prior to Hagrid's birth in 1928
Fred welfare first met Hagrid's dad the
historical records never revealed his
full name so we only know him as Mr
Hagrid although giantesses and men had
been known to Wed each other it wasn't a
very common practice as you could guess
Wizards and witches frowned upon mixed
marriages and even the Giants who valued
size and power Above All Else looked
down on their peers who married weak
human wizards but Fred wolfer and Mr
Hagrid actually gave their relationship
an honest attempt and they were happy
for a while mother's abandonment
in December of 1928 Fred wolfer and Mr
Hagrid welcomed their son rubius into
the world almost instantly red walther's
demeanor changed in giant culture they
prided themselves on having the largest
strongest babies and after a quick
glance at the infant rubius Fred wolfer
realized that she had failed as a half
giant rubius was a fraction of the size
of other giant babies ashamed by her
child's small stature Fred Wolford
decided to run away and fled back to her
giant Colony before Hogwarts in the
years it followed young rubius Hagrid
lived a simple life with his father
Hagrid doesn't say much about his old
man but he seemed to be an honest kind
wizard before Hagrid was even old enough
to attend primary school he had already
grown six feet tall often he would throw
his father over his shoulders and haul
him around the house and yard
although Hagrid and his father had a
strong relationship Hagrid's social life
suffered outside of the home as a half
giant other parents would often warn
their children about playing with him it
wasn't until Hagrid received his
acceptance letter to Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and was a dream that the
young boy thought he could finally find
a close-knit group of friends problems
but Hogwarts wasn't very different from
the real world for Hagrid his first
semester began in 1940 and though it's
not stated anywhere it's likely that he
was sorted into house Gryffindor at
school he continued to suffer as his
fellow students ridiculed and bullied
him often rubius would turn his
attention to magical beasts and
creatures in order to find companionship
although this hobby often landed the
half Giant in trouble with Hogwarts
faculty by his third year at school
Hagrid had grown to nearly 11 feet in
height but unfortunately he continued to
struggle socially the recent death death
of his father who was his closest friend
only made matters worse if he were
anyone else he'd use his natural Brawn
to turn the tide against his bullies but
Hagrid's low self-esteem and non-violent
disposition made him a natural Target
eventually Tom Riddle who was only a few
years older than Hagrid at the time
decided to frame Hagrid for a recent
murder at the school riddle was actually
the one responsible for the crime but he
managed to convince the ministry of
magic that one of Hagrid's dangerous
pets an acromantula named aragog was the
culprit in the aftermath Hagrid was
expelled from Hogwarts and forbidden
from using a wand again but thanks to
Albus Dumbledore's quick intervention
Hagrid was saved from going back into
the real world as an orphan Dumbledore
managed to land Hagrid a role studying
how to become a groundskeeper this
gesture of kindness might have been
enough to keep Hagrid from a life of
crime
with his father gone the young half
giant had nowhere to turn and the fate
of giants in The Wizarding World was
usually a bloody painful one Official
Game Keeper so as the years passed
Hagrid grew and grew under Dumbledore's
watchful eye rubius lived a peaceful
life with each passing semester The
Faculty entrusted the young half giant
with more responsibilities until
eventually he was promoted to headground
keeper sometime before 1967 succeeding
the previous groundskeeper OGG Hagrid's
role went by many titles gamekeeper
grandkeeper and keeper of keys on any
given day Hagrid could be seen securing
the Hogwarts grounds from Intruders or
dropping down pine trees to decorate the
Great Hall for Christmas dinner but the
pot Hagrid loved the most was tending to
the magical beasts that Hogwarts raised
first Wizarding War the years passed
faster and by the 1970s rubius Hagrid
found himself quickly becoming a senior
member of the staff at Hogwarts but that
wasn't what he remembered most about
those years the 1970s was the start of
Lord Voldemort's first campaign against
the ministry a conflict known as the
first Wizarding War for the next 10
years Hagrid Faithfully served Albus
Dumbledore and the Order of the Phoenix
as they fought against Voldemort and his
Death Eaters when the Dog Wizard finally
fell in his failed assassination of
Harry Potter Hagrid was dispatched to
retrieve the infant and return him to
safety acromantula injury between that
fateful night and the next time Hagrid
would see Harry Potter very little
changed in the half Giant's life he
continued to work as the gamekeeper at
Hogwarts tending to the Aging castle and
the creatures who lived there at one
point while wandering around the
Forbidden Forest Hagrid's love of the
tarantula-like acromantula nearly cost
him his life one of the creatures bit
Hagrid and injected enough Venom to
overwhelm his enhanced immune system
after a short stay in hospital Hagrid
was back on his feet and returned to the
Forbidden Forest to spend time with
those creatures once more reconnecting
with Harry in 1991 Hagrid ventured
through England to find Harry Potter's
last known location at that time his
adoptive parents the dursleys refused to
send the boy to Hogwarts hoping to find
a secluded home where not even Albus
Dumbledore could find them Potter and
the dursleys ended up on a tiny Island
appropriately named Hut on the rock it
wasn't long before Hagrid tracked Harry
down though and after a brief shouting
match with Harry's Uncle the half giant
took Potter on his very first Adventure
in The Wizarding World just like like
many male role models in Harry's life
Hagrid quickly became one of the boy's
most important father figures especially
in Harry's early years when he suffered
as an outcast Hagrid was always around
to lend an ear Azkaban but after Harry
returned to the Wizarding World so did
another Force Lord Voldemort and he was
desperate to take on true physical form
at first he attempted to steal the
Philosopher's Stone at one point his
accomplice in the pursuit Professor
Quirrell managed to dupe Hagrid into
revealing how to get around Hogwarts
newest security measure a three-headed
dog the very next year Hagrid got in
more trouble and messages appeared on
Hogwarts wall claiming that the Chamber
of Secrets was once again opened with
the original reason for Hagrid's
expulsion fresh on everyone's mind the
ministry quickly determined Hagrid was
the villain behind everything and sent
him to Azkaban to rot away after Harry
Potter discovered the truth destroyed
but the Basilisk and the Diary of Tom
Riddle the ministry allowed Hagrid to
return a professor as the years between
the Battle of Hogwarts grew shorter and
shorter Harry Potter's list of mentors
and allies grew longer and longer once
Hagrid was perhaps the most important
figure in the young Wizard's life but
that would all change although not all
change was bad for Hagrid by Harry's
third year Hagrid became a professor
taking on teaching responsibilities for
the care of magical creatures the title
of professor at Hogwarts was quite an
impressive feat compared to Hagrid's own
classmates who had actually graduated
from Hogwarts the half giant actually
ended up as one of the most accomplished
the next year when the trial was a
tournament concluded and Voldemort took
on a new body Hagrid was assigned a
particularly tough task by the Order of
the Phoenix fearing that the Giants
might once again align themselves with
Voldemort in the dark woods acids Hagrid
went to their secret colonies to bring
them to his side the mission seemed like
it might actually succeed but on one of
the very first Nights At The Colony a
giant aligned with dark Wizards killed
the ruling Chieftain and turned the
tribe away from Hagrid and Dumbledore's
Alliance Hagrid's time with the Giants
wasn't an entire failure though as he
discovered one of his few living
relatives a brother named grop Hagrid
returned to Hogwarts keeping his
brother's existence a secret in the
Forbidden Forest but his time there was
short-lived when Dolores Umbridge took
over Albus Dumbledore's position Hagrid
was forced out his Exile didn't last
long though as Dumbledore eventually
returned but the months that followed
continued with conflict after conflict
it all culminated with the battle of the
astronomy Tower where Severus Snape
killed Albus Dumbledore through a
torrent of Tears Hagrid carried the old
Wizard's body and funeral laying him to
rest as the latest victim of Voldemort's
new war Hagrid would be placed in a
similarly Grim scenario the following
year when Harry Potter fought against
Voldemort and nearly died while Harry
was in limbo Hagrid carried the lifeless
corpse just as he had done for
Dumbledore this time though Potter
managed to come back to life and finish
the fight against Voldemort striking him
dead during the Battle of Hogwarts in
the years that followed hackard
continued to work at Hogwarts as late as
2019 Hagrid was seen guiding young
Wizards as they learned how to perfect
their spells by that time Hagrid was one
of the longest serving staff members of
all time having spent 80 years at the
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry and
that's it for this video did you know
much about Hagrid's life his Beginnings
what video do you want next be sure to
leave a comment down below until next
time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live